друзі всіх вітаємо сьогодні дуже важливе
засідання Верховної Ради України адже
згідно новому закону про медіа нарешті
телеканал Рада якій було віддано в
лізингу офісу президента буде змушений в
трансляції але демонструвати сьогоднішнє
засідання і тоді вся країна дізнається
що завдяки боротьбі опозиції Ми
повернули сьогодні доплати нашим
військовим прикордонникам нашим
поліцейським всім тим хто має право
отримувати гідні виплати Отже 30 000 грн
має бути повернута тим хто їх сьогодні
Ну більше за все заслуговує це Україна
необхідна поправка а також ми
будемо дослухалася і в тому числі
розглядала наші законодавчі ініціативи
які також спрямовані на Забезпечення
захисту
військовослужбовців та членів яких
одиниця ви пам'ятаєте коли пан Данилов
говорив про те що відміна тридцятки - це
така собі справедливість крім де
мотивації і несправедливого підходу
нічого Вона не мала сьогодні коли у
вигляді поправки ці норми внесені в
закон і тепер закон буде регулюватися
виплата 30 000 100 000 військовим а не
постановою Кабмін на яку вони можуть
змінювати під покровом в любий момент і
в тайні від народних депутатів Ми
повернули цю норму і сподіваюсь що
Президент не накладе в это і дуже
важливо що в цій поправці також було
обмеження граничне обмеження виплат
заробітних плат і всіх видів премій
тобто всіх нарахувань які здійснюються
для державних службовців для
Національного банку для кабінету
міністрів для народних депутатів для
всіх депутатів Тобто там де є
нарахування з державного бюджету
граничний розмір може складати лише 10
мінімальних розмірів заробітної плати Це
6 7 тисяч гривень на сьогоднішній день
не забувайте що ця норма буде
стосуватися і державних підприємств що
не мало важливо де ви чули вже
неодноразово що зарплати сягають до 1
млн грн в місяць якщо президент не
накладе в это на ці поправки то
Насправді всі ці ресурси які вивівняться
будуть спрямовані на доплату 30 тисяч і
буде І це буде якраз справедливо під час
війни такий підхід все та мене є явним і
тому Верховна Рада сьогодні виправила цю
ганьбу ми дуже часто
чули це від військовослужбовців і дійсно
уряд вже не буде таємно приймати якісь
такі постанови коли Верховна Рада буде
змушена це все виправляти і Ми змушені
про це публічно говорити дай боже щоб
наша дискусії показували по єдиному
марафону але ще хотілось би додати що
дійсно оці зарплати керівників державних
підприємств особливо нафтогазової галузі
по більше ніж Три мільйона гривень і
поєднання теж керівників декількох
державних підприємств це теж ганьба піде
в минуле і хотілось би єдине щоб за це
несли відповідальність особливо ті хто
їх призначав і ті хто працював на ці
посади
прикро що так довго довелося добиватися
повернення справедливості для наших
захисників але тішимося що нарешті це
вдалося тепер м'яч на половині поля
президента України і я сподіваюся що в
Марафоні нарешті будуть розповідати а
правду і те що ви будете бачити що
відбувається у Верховній Раді України
допоможе вам розібратися і не
звинувачувати парламентарів у тому
безладі і тому безладі який дуже часто
робить кабінет міністрів це саме те що
відбулося з тими 30-ма тисячами які
сьогодні законом повернула Верховна Рада
України з нетерпінням чекаємо підписи
наприклад на проекти вважаємо що
Президент Зеленський не повинен цим
зволікати Ну якщо говорити про інше
важливі речі які голосувалися сьогодні
на засіданні парламенту то це і
звернення до парламентів світу закликом
щоби на вільнюскому саміті НАТО Україна
отримала чіткий сигнал щодо нашого члена
також було порушено в чергове тут закон
і відправлено у відставку голову
рахункової палати пана пацкана ми
вважаємо що одна із причин стало те що
рахункова палата сьогодні дуже чітко
відслідковують і неправові дії які
відбуваються в самому парламенті зокрема
з каналом ради який вперше віддано в
лізинг офісу президента України Ну і
Повірте будь ласка що європейська
Солідарність стоїть на захисті наших
військовослужбовців і зараз будемо
наполягати на тому що ми були прийняті
наши закони про необхідність негайної
модернізації військово-лікарських
комісій Тому що наші поранення не
повинні місяцями чекати виплат і довідок
це буде Україна друзі До побачення